so I've told you that Donald Trump's
approval rating has sort of been
bouncing up and down between 35 and 40
disturbing shock that there are still 35
or 40 percent of the country that
approve of the job Trump is doing but
it's not worth reporting on on a
day-to-day basis today I actually have
some other interesting numbers to look
at with you there's a new poll from
Quinnipiac University and it was a poll
about whether people believe Donald
Trump is fit to be President of the
United States according to Americans and
the results are pretty damn bad a
majority of Americans now say that
Donald Trump is unfit for office and
most of us will hear this and will say
of course Donald Trump is unfit for
office but the fact that the need the
fact that that news that feeling has
moved into actual polling data actually
does make a difference so according to
Quinnipiac 56% of all Americans now say
that Donald Trump is just flat-out not
fit to serve as president of the United
States but remember most voters agreed
Donald Trump shouldn't be President of
the United States 54% of the of the
ballots cast in November of 2016 were
for someone other than Trump Trump got
46% of the votes in November so the math
of it not really confusing or surprising
but this now gets beyond approval
approval is do you agree with what the
president is doing rather than do you
believe that he is fit to serve you
could think that what the president is
doing is bad and therefore you don't
approve of the job but still believe
that the president is fit to be
President of the United States so like
Nixon I guess would be an example for
people on the Left where I think most
people on the Left would say I I didn't
agree with Nixon's policy but he was
smart and he was qualified and fit to be
President of the United States maybe
it's a bad example but it's an example
now you are actually seeing a majority
of the country or the country that says
this is not about the specific policies
of Donald Trump
we don't believe a majority of the
country does not believe that Trump is
that a fundamental level fit to be
President of the United States now
there's a major gender divide on this
and there's a major racial divide on
this on gender
men are split 49 to 49 as to whether
they believe Trump is fit to be
President or not 63% of women closer to
a two-to-one ratio say that Donald Trump
is not fit to be President of the United
States and then on race the divide is
gigantic white voters are basically 5050
50 percent of white voters say Trump's
not fit to be President
50 percent of white voters say Trump is
fit to be President
ninety-four percent of black voters
believe Donald Trump is not fit to be
President of the United States and 60%
of his fetta Hispanic voters say that
Donald Trump is not fit to be President
of the United States we're eight months
in right the more interesting question
for me is becoming what could move up
Donald Trump's approval rating 1/3
Obamacare repeal is dead we could say
well Trump has this new tax plan the tax
plan that I analyzed in detail is good
mostly for the very rich if it passes it
should actually hurt Trump's approval
because it's not a good tax plan for
most Americans if people actually
understand what's in the tax plan I fear
people will see it as an accomplishment
you could say well building that wall
and getting Mexico to pay for it would
increase Trump's approval rating I don't
know only about 35 or 40 percent of
Americans even want that done so I
really don't know what would move the
needle we're still in year one and
things are this bad and many times when
it comes to approval rating the story is
what have you done for me lately right
with Trump eight months in is what have
you done for me ever what have you done
for me ever but Republicans are mostly
standing by him 84 percent of
Republicans still believe that Donald
Trump is fit to be President of the
United States and that statistic is why
I've been saying and I will continue to
say it is not worth trying to change the
minds of Republican voters who support
Trump work on getting out the vote right
I mean half the country didn't vote you
can win elections just by getting people
already on your side to choose to vote
on Election Day you do not need to
convince anyone to change their mind
just convince them that their vote
matters which should be easy since just
80,000 votes across three states led to
Donald Trump being President of the
United States despite losing the popular
vote by millions and millions of votes
so if we've ever needed more
confirmation that it is just not worth
any of our time trying to convince Trump
is to vote for somebody else work on get
out the vote because 84% of Republicans
still approve of the job that Donald
Trump is doing